Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove's seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th. US-only exclusions apply.
Home Depot 的阵亡将士纪念日促销让您的夏天从现在开始。是时候用新品四气眼烧烤炉开启夏日派对啦，特价仅需 199 美元。还有汉普顿湾西格罗夫七件套户外餐桌椅，整个季节都能尽情招待亲友，只需 49 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在 Home Depot 享受全场超低价承诺。库存有限，价格有效期至 5 月 14 日或 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，受相关条款约束。
See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. It's no surprise that we homo sapiens tend to have a human-centric view of intelligence. When we think of smart animals, we generally think of primates or other animals close to us on the evolutionary tree. But octopuses shake up this view of the world. They haven't shared a common ancestor with humans in at least 600 million years. But somehow, these invertebrates evolved remarkable problem-solving abilities, curiosity, and an intelligence all their own. So what do we know about how octopuses think and how they experience the world? How and why did they evolve to be so curious and smart? How are their brain structured?
详情请参见 Home Depot.com/pricematch。毫无疑问，我们智人对智能的看法往往是以人类为中心的。当我们想到聪明的动物时，通常会想到灵长类动物或其他在进化树上与我们相近的动物。但章鱼打破了这种世界观。它们与人类至少有 6.000 万年没有共同祖先了。但不知何故，这些无脊椎动物进化出了非凡的解决问题能力、好奇心以及独一无二的智力。那么，关于章鱼是如何思考以及它们是如何体验世界的，我们知道些什么呢？它们是如何以及为什么进化得如此好奇和聪明的？它们的脑结构是怎样的？
And what can we learn about thinking and intelligence in general from studying how octopuses behave? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Jennifer Mather, a professor of psychology at the University of Lethbridge in Alberta, Canada, and one of the world's leading experts on octopus behavior. Dr. Mather has spent decades studying cephalopods, marine animals that include octopuses, cuddlfish, and squids. Her fieldwork has taken her around the world to places including Bermuda, Hawaii, Bon Air, and the Pacific Island, Moria. She's authored dozens of academic papers and is co-author of the book Octopus, The Ocean's Intelligent Invertebrate. She was also the scientific advisor to the Netflix film My Octopus Teacher, which won the 2021 Academy Award for Best Documentary.
从研究章鱼的行为中，我们能对普遍的思考和智能学到什么？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是詹妮弗·马瑟（Jennifer Mather）博士，她是加拿大阿尔伯塔省莱斯布里奇大学的心理学教授，也是全球顶尖的章鱼行为专家之一。马瑟博士花了几十年时间研究头足类动物，这类海洋动物包括章鱼、墨鱼和鱿鱼。她的实地考察足迹遍布全球，包括百慕大、夏威夷、博内尔岛以及太平洋岛屿莫雷阿岛。她撰写了数十篇学术论文，并合著了《章鱼：海洋智能无脊椎动物》（Octopus, The Ocean's Intelligent Invertebrate）一书。她还是 Netflix 电影《我的章鱼老师》（My Octopus Teacher）的科学顾问，该片荣获 2021 年奥斯卡最佳纪录片奖。
And if you haven't watched it, you really should. Dr. Mather, thank you for joining me today. It's good to be here. And I mentioned in the introduction that octopuses are very far removed from us on the evolutionary tree. so far removed that some people compare meeting an octopus to meeting an alien life form. What do you think of that analogy? Oh, I'm not really happy about that. Let's say that life on this planet is very, very diverse.
如果你还没看过，真的应该去看一看。马瑟博士，非常感谢你今天能来。很高兴来到这里。我在引言中提到，章鱼在进化树上离我们非常遥远。远到有人将与章鱼相遇比作与外星生命相遇。你对这个类比有什么看法？哦，我其实不太喜欢这种说法。应该说，这个星球上的生命是非常非常多样化的。
So octopuses are completely not like us. On the other hand, honeybees are completely not like us, and they're not like octopuses either. So octopuses give us a glimpse into diversity. Why do you believe that octopus has evolved to be so intelligent? What were the evolutionary pressures at work? Probably the evolutionary pressures were the competition of the bony fishes. Because the bony fishes evolved about the time that the chileoids cephalopods evolved. And bony fishes really now dominate the ocean.
所以章鱼和我们完全不像。另一方面，蜜蜂和我们完全不像，它们和章鱼也不一样。因此，章鱼让我们得以一窥多样性。你认为章鱼为什么会进化得如此聪明？当时起作用的进化压力是什么？进化压力可能来自硬骨鱼的竞争。因为硬骨鱼进化的时候，刚好也是蛸亚纲头足类动物进化的时候。现在硬骨鱼确实主宰了海洋。
They're fast, they're smart, they're maneuverable. And to keep up with them, the cephalopods had to, evolve, if not necessarily to be fast, maybe to be smart. Do you have any salient examples of behavior that show how smart or curious octopuses are? I mean, what can they do that might surprise people? But one of the things that everybody quotes is what they call the coconut carrying octopuses in Australia. And a group of octopuses dug out, separated coconut halves from the muddy sand. and wandered off across in the open area, carrying them underneath them.
它们速度快、聪明、灵活。为了跟上它们的步伐，头足类动物不得不进化，即使不一定非要变得速度快，也许也得变得聪明。你有什么突出的行为例子可以说明章鱼有多聪明或多好奇吗？我的意思是，它们能做哪些可能会让人们大吃一惊的事情呢？但每个人都会引用的事情之一，就是他们在澳大利亚所说的“搬运椰子的章鱼”。一群章鱼从泥沙中挖出、分理出对半开的椰子壳。然后把它们顶在身底下，一路蹒跚着穿过开阔区域。
And after a while, when they got to the point that they wanted to stop and rest, they dropped the two halves, separate them, neatly line them up, crawl inside, pull it over between them, I guess you'd call it, and find themselves a perfect shelter. That's really interesting because that's something that has been called mental time travel, which is thinking about how the world is going to be in the future and making plans for what to do about it. That's pretty amazing, and that reminds me of a scene in my octopus teacher where the octopus that was basically the star of the show created a kind of armor using old shells and seafloor detritus, and it appeared to be very deliberate behavior to protect itself from a predator shark.
过了一会儿，当它们走到想停下来休息的地方时，它们放下两半椰子，把它们分开，整齐地排成一行，然后爬进去，拉过椰子盖在自己身上——我想你可以这么叫它——为自己找到了一个完美的庇护所。这真的很有趣，因为这被称为“心理时间旅行”，也就是思考未来世界会是什么样，并为之做出计划。这太神奇了，这让我想起了《我的章鱼老师》中的一个场景：作为该片绝对主角的那只章鱼利用旧贝壳和海底碎屑制作了一种盔甲，这似乎是一种为了保护自己免受捕食性鲨鱼侵害的蓄意行为。
We often hear that there are very few animals that use tools like we humans do, but does this behavior and the coconut behavior indicate that octopuses are also using tools? Oh, absolutely. And one of the ways in which it's really clear is that they will hide in some kind of shelter. And of course, the shelters have different sizes of entrances as well as different spaces behind. And way back when I was studying octopuses in Bermuda, I was trying to figure out. how you could characterize their shelters. And one thing I noticed is the bigger the entrance, the more likely the octopus was to bring rocks and shells and pile them up in front of it to make the entrance smaller.
我们经常听到，很少有动物像我们人类那样使用工具，但这这种行为以及搬运椰子的行为是否表明章鱼也在使用工具呢？哦，绝对是的。其中一个很明显的证明方式就是，它们会躲进某种庇护所里。当然，庇护所的入口大小以及后面的空间也各不相同。很久以前，我在百慕大研究章鱼时，我曾试图弄清楚你该如何描述它们的庇护所。我注意到的一件事是，入口越大，章鱼就越有可能把石头和贝壳搬来堆在入口前面，好把入口变小。
And there's tool use. But actually, my favorite tool use of theirs is they have a flexible siphon or funnel, which is really exhaloned as it would be if we blew our water. and they use this water jet for a whole bunch of things. They use it to clean out holes. They use it to repel nuisances, not really big predators, but nuisances, which includes, of course, my roping hand when I'm feeling around their home and trying to figure out what they've had for lunch yesterday.
这就是工具的使用。但事实上，我最喜欢它们使用工具的方式是，它们有一个灵活的虹吸管或漏斗，这其实就像我们喷水时排出的水流一样。它们用这个水流喷射来做很多事情。它们用它来清理洞穴，用它来驱赶讨厌的家伙，不是那种真正的捕食大敌，而是讨厌的东西，当然这其中也包括当我把手伸进它们的家、试图摸索它们昨天午餐吃了什么时，我那只被它们当成绳索抓的手。
So one of my favorite anecdotes, I really have to tell you this one, they have the giant Pacific octopus pre-will all the time at the Seattle Aquarium. And these animals are active at night, and they prefer that it's dark at night. And there was one situation where they had the night light on over top of the octopus tag. And the octopus simply reached up with its siphon, jetted a jet of water at the light, and shorted it out. What the heck? You have to wonder how it figured out that it. could do that. My guess is that they would have a general habit of jetting water nuisances
所以，我最喜欢的轶事之一——我真的必须告诉你这个——西雅图水族馆一直养着巨型太平洋章鱼。这些动物在夜间活动，而且它们更喜欢夜里黑漆漆的。有一次，章鱼展池上方开着一盏夜灯。这只章鱼竟然直接用它的虹吸管对准灯喷射了一股水柱，把灯给弄短路了。搞什么鬼？你不得不惊叹它是怎么想出自己能做到这一点的。我猜它们本来就有一种习惯，会朝讨厌的东西喷水。
like pesky researchers and scavenging fish. And there are reports of octopuses in labs that have done things like squirted at researchers that maybe they didn't like for some reason. I mean, it was always the same person, right? When there's one octopus was doing that. Let me ask you, are we anthropomorphizing them or do they have distinct personalities? Well, there's two questions there. The first question is, can they tell individual humans apart? And with my colleague Roland Anderson at the Seattle Aquarium, we did conduct tests to see whether they could recognize individual humans.
比如讨厌的研究人员和食腐鱼类。据实验室里的章鱼报告，它们做过一些事情，比如向它们可能出于某种原因不喜欢的研究人员喷水。我的意思是，总是同一个人，对吧？当时有一只章鱼在这么做。请问，我们是在拟人化它们，还是它们拥有鲜明的个性？嗯，这里有两个问题。第一个问题是，它们能分辨出不同的人类吗？通过与我在西雅图水族馆的同事罗兰·安德森（Roland Anderson）合作，我们进行了测试，看看它们是否能识别不同的人类。
And the answer was, yes, they can. And by the way, the two subjects, one of whom, of course, was Ron, dressed in the same Seattle Aquarium T-shirt. So that clue wasn't available to them. And we didn't actually figure out what clues were available, although there were different shapes and sizes. Still, that's pretty good. They can tell us apart.
答案是，是的，它们能。顺便说一句，两个测试对象（其中一个当然是罗恩）穿的是同一件西雅图水族馆 T 恤。所以这个线索对它们来说是没有用的。而且我们实际上并没有弄清楚它们利用了哪些线索，尽管形状和大小有所不同。尽管如此，这已经相当厉害了。它们能分清我们。
Now, you've written that octopuses are tremendous explorers and that they really have an insatiable desire for moving around. I mean, they just don't stay in one place. Can you talk about that? What does that look like in the wilder, even in an aquarium? What happens to an octopus that is an explorer and is confined? Well, I'm really jealous, actually, of the octopus arms. because they've got eight of them, and they can explore separately with every one of them.
现在，你曾写过章鱼是极好的探险者，它们确实有着永无止境的到处移动的渴望。我的意思是，它们就是不会呆在一个地方。你能谈谈这个吗？在野外甚至在水族馆里，这看起来是什么样的？一只生性爱探险却被关起来的章鱼会发生什么？嗯，其实我真的很嫉妒章鱼的触手。因为它们有八条触手，每一条都可以独立探险。
So actually, when they're hunting, they're not actually hunting by fission. They go to likely places, and then they stick their arms and crevices and snake them along cracks and explore the algae by sort of fueling up the stems and down the leaves. And so all the time, they're picking up information through their suckers. By the way, each sucker has hundreds of chemical and tactile. and each arm has hundreds of suckers. So they've got tons and tons of information. Speaking of information and how octopuses gather it, I mean, they're clearly using their arms for a lot of this work, but they do have brains. In fact, I understand they have more than one brain.
所以实际上，当它们捕猎时，它们并不是通过分裂来捕猎的。它们会去那些可能藏有猎物的地方，然后将触手伸进石缝中，顺着裂缝蜿蜒前行，通过在茎部上下搜寻来探索藻类。就这样，它们一直在通过吸盘收集信息。顺便说一下，每个吸盘都有数百个化学和触觉感受器。每条触手都有数百个吸盘。所以它们拥有海量的信息。说到信息以及章鱼是如何收集信息的，我的意思是，它们显然用触手完成了大部分工作，但它们确实有大脑。事实上，据我所知，它们不止一个大脑。
I mean, how is the octopus brain organized? No, no, it's a popular fallacy. They have one central brain. But what this comes from is the fact that only two-fifths of the nerves of the octopus are in the brain. Three-fifths are out there in the arms, and each arm, in fact, has a chain of ganglia down its dorsal surface. Each one of these ganglia is actually centered over one of the suckers. And though there's a sucker ganglion, this chain of ganglia is really, really responsible for making sure the suckers do what they're supposed to do and feel and smell what they're supposed to do, okay? But they're not a brain. One thing to call them is a plexus, and a plexus is a series of same units, which does have some organization, but it doesn't have a
我的意思是，章鱼的大脑是如何组织的？不，不，这是一个普遍的误解。它们只有一个中央大脑。但这种说法源于这样一个事实：章鱼只有五分之二的神经在大脑中。五分之三在触手上，事实上，每条触手的背侧表面都有一串神经节。这些神经节中的每一个实际上都位于一个吸盘的正上方。虽然有一个吸盘神经节，但这串神经节确实非常负责任地确保吸盘做出它们应该做出的反应，并感受和嗅出它们应该感知的东西，好吗？但它们不是大脑。称呼它们的一种方式是“丛”（plexus），而“丛”是一系列相同的单元，它确实具有某种组织结构，但它没有一个。
central controller. Another way to look at it is what's going on, and the arms is subroutines. So the octopus brain doesn't tell the arms what to do in detail. Somebody described it as the octopus brain tells the ganglia what to tell the arms to do. There's an evolutionary reason for this, and I have to back up a little bit. Octopuses have no bones. And when you think about it, if you had no bones, how could you possibly move whole things, move parts of you around?
中央控制器。看待这个问题的另一种方式是，在触手中发生的事情就像是子程序。所以章鱼的大脑并不会向触手详细下达具体怎么做的指令。有人将其形容为：章鱼的大脑告诉神经节该命令触手做什么。这背后有一个进化的原因，我得稍微倒回来说一下。章鱼没有骨头。仔细想想，如果你没有骨头，你怎么可能移动整个身体，或者移动身体的各个部分呢？
And the answer to that is specifically in the arms that the octopus stiffens some of the muscles to act as temporary skeletons. And then the other muscles articulate against those temporary skeletons. It's really way more flexibility than we have. But if you think about it, you couldn't possibly program all that in the brain. So what the brain does is it sends out general signals to the ganglia and the ganglia go, oh, okay, I'm supposed to do this.
这个问题的答案具体就在于章鱼的触手上，它们收紧一些肌肉来充当临时的骨骼。然后其他肌肉以这些临时骨骼为支点进行运动。这确实比我们拥有大得多的灵活性。但仔细想想，你绝不可能在脑子里把所有这些都编程好。所以大脑所做的就是向神经节发出一般性信号，而神经节就会想：“哦，好的，我该这么做。”
So it's true that the arms have a lot of autonomy. There are octopuses, long-armed octopuses, that actually have autonomy that they can cast off an arm if they're threatened. And one of these cast-off arms will actually crawl down your hand, and the suckers will make contact with whatever is underneath them. There's a rumor. I've never seen this, but anyway, first of all, I should say that if an item out there in the environment is not terribly interesting and small, the octopus may reach out an arm, hold onto it with the suckers at the tip, and passes sucker by sucker by sucker by sucker up to the mouth to decide whether it's useful in hand or good to taste.
所以，触手确实具有很大的自主性。有些章鱼，比如长腕章鱼，在受到威胁时甚至真的可以自主舍弃一条触手。其中一条被舍弃的触手实际上会沿着你的手爬行，吸盘会与它底下的任何东西接触。有个传闻。我从来没见过这个，不过无论如何，首先我应该说，如果环境中的某个东西既不是非常有趣又很小，章鱼可能会伸出触手，用尖端的吸盘抓住它，然后一个接一个、一个接一个地把这个东西往上递到嘴边，以决定它在手里是否有用，或者尝起来味道是否好。
and I've done an ethogram, which is a description of all the behaviors of the octopuses. And in this particular case, I called this action conveyor belt. But the rumor is, and I haven't seen this, but the rumor is that an arm that has been cast off from the body can pick up a sucker and pass it from sucker to sucker to sucker towards the month that isn't there anymore. So that's a lot of organization, but it's not a brain because it's not a decision maker. And for me, subroutines is the best way to think about it. This isn't exactly a psychological question, but since you know so much about cephalopods, and I don't, how do octopuses camouflage themselves so well?
我曾制作过一份行为谱（ethogram），也就是对章鱼所有行为的描述。在这个特定的例子中，我把这个动作叫做“传送带”。但传闻是——我还没亲眼见过，但传闻说——从身体上脱落下来的一条触手可以捡起一个吸盘，然后一个接一个、一个接一个地把东西朝着那个已经不存在的嘴巴方向传递。所以这里面有大量的组织结构，但它不是大脑，因为它不是决策者。对我来说，“子程序”是思考这个问题的最佳方式。这不完全是一个心理学问题，但既然你对头足类动物了解这么多，而我并不了解，章鱼是怎么把自己伪装得这么好的呢？
My understanding is that they have very limited color vision. So what does it work when they do this? Well, it's terribly ironic. They do not have color vision, and yet they can use color and camouflage. And exactly how they do it, we do not know. It's one of the big paradoxes of octopus behavior. But they have fabulous camouflage. And the reason they have such good camouflage is they have many organs in the skin, chromatophores.
据我所知，它们的色觉非常有限。那么它们在做这件事时，原理是什么呢？嗯，这极其具有讽刺意味。它们没有色觉，然而它们却能利用颜色进行伪装。它们究竟是如何做到这一点的，我们并不知道。这是章鱼行为中最大的悖论之一。但它们的伪装堪称一绝。它们之所以能伪装得这么好，是因为它们的皮肤里有许多器官——色素细胞（chromatophores）。
Each of those chromatophores is an elastic sack containing pigments that are either yellow or red or brown black. And each of those elastic sacks has muscles pulling it out. So when the muscles relax, you can't see anything. You can see the reflective surfaces below. When they pull it out, suddenly you see the color. And the reason they're so good at this is, given that it's muscles, they could be very specific.
每一个色素细胞都是一个弹性囊，里面含有黄色、红色或棕黑色的色素。每一个弹性囊都有肌肉将其拉开。因此，当肌肉放松时，你什么也看不见。你只能看到下方反光的表面。当它们拉开色素细胞时，你突然就能看到颜色了。它们之所以能如此擅长此道，鉴于这是由肌肉驱动的，它们可以做到非常精确。
So there's really more to control to an area of it. a millimeter square, probably smaller, and they're very fast. So they can change color in about 33 milliseconds. And with that kind of combination, you could do anything you like. Now, there are some great videos out there that show Octopus is doing what looks like playing, whether they're batting a fish or doing the equivalent of bouncing a ball. Is that what they're doing? Is it your belief that they're actually playing?
所以对于一平方毫米甚至可能更小的一片区域，其实有更多的控制维度，而且它们的动作非常快。因此它们可以在大约 33 毫秒内改变颜色。有了这种组合，你可以做任何你想做的事。现在，有一些很棒的视频展示了章鱼在做看起来像是在玩耍的行为，无论是拍打一条鱼，还是做出相当于拍球的动作。这就是它们在做的事吗？你认为它们真的在玩耍吗？
Well, it was actually one of my research projects, again, with Roland Anderson, because we figured if any invertebrate plays, it would be the octopuses. And I had to call it Sergio Pellas, who is a specialist of a Malian play, who's written a couple of books on play. And I remember asking him one day whether he thought that octopuses would play. And he said, well, given what you told me about them, maybe. So Roland and I set up a situation, and we figured. for them to play, they'd have to be bored and safe and have something that was worth manipulating. This is one of my favorite studies of all times, by the way, for a very interesting reason. So we set up a situation where we had octopuses in the lab at the aquarium.
嗯，这其实是我的研究项目之一，同样也是和罗兰·安德森（Roland Anderson）合作的，因为我们觉得如果有什么无脊椎动物会玩耍，那一定非章鱼莫属。我当时打电话给塞尔吉奥·佩拉斯（Sergio Pellis），他是哺乳动物玩耍行为的专家，曾写过几本关于玩耍的书。我记得有一天我问他，他是否认为章鱼会玩耍。他说，嗯，鉴于你对我说过的关于它们的种种，也许会的。于是罗兰和我设定了一个场景，我们琢磨着。
There was nothing in the lab except a place to hide and a floating pill bottle, which was, I guess it had about one quarter full of water, so it floated gently on the surface. and the first reaction of all the six octopuses we used was to just grab it, pull it into the mouth, feel around with the suckers, and figure out that it wasn't worth anything in terms of food and let it go. Two of the six, by about the fourth trial,
要想让它们玩耍，它们必须觉得无聊、安全，并且拥有值得摆弄的东西。顺便说一句，这也是我最喜欢的研究之一，原因非常有趣。因此，我们建立了一个场景，将章鱼放在水族馆的实验室里。实验室里除了一个躲藏的地方和一个漂浮的药丸瓶之外什么也没有，我想那个瓶子里大概装了四分之一的水，所以它在水面上轻轻漂浮着。我们使用的所有六只章鱼的最初反应都是一把抓住它，把它拉进嘴里，用吸盘四处摸索，弄清楚它在食物方面毫无价值后就把它放开了。在这六只章鱼中，有两只大约在第四次试验时，
used, and this was actually serendipity, because we had the octopus at one end of the aquarium and the water intake for circulation at the other end. So two of the octopuses aimed a water jet and sent the pill bottle down to the intake where it came floating back to them. Now, if you do it once, you're not going to call that play. I think one of them was 16 times,
利用了——这其实是个巧合，因为我们将章鱼放在水族馆的一端，而用于水循环的进水口在另一端。其中两只章鱼瞄准方向喷出一股水流，把药丸瓶冲到了进水口那里，瓶子随后又漂流回了它们身边。现在，如果你只做了一次，你不会把这称为玩耍。我想其中一只做了 16 次，
and one of them was 10 times. And that's play. Having contacts with the world of animal play has been some time talking to surgery and also to Gordon Berghardt, who has gave a book on play. and Gordon discusses this situation and says it passes all the rules for play. And the animals are doing this alone, right? I mean, you can't put two octopuses in the same tank.
另一只做了 10 次。这就是玩耍。为了解动物玩耍的世界，我花了一些时间与塞尔吉奥交谈，也跟写过一本关于玩耍的书的戈登·伯格哈特（Gordon Burghardt）聊过。戈登讨论了这种情况，并表示它符合玩耍的所有规则。而且这些动物都是独自完成这一点的，对吧？我的意思是，你不能把两只章鱼放进同一个水箱里。
Well, it depends on the species. But yes, there are some species where if you put two octopuses in the same tank, you'll end up with one welfare octopus. And that's a characteristic of the whole group, which means you really can never count on them being truly social, because they are all potentially at least cannibalistic. And that's why you're not going to see Octopus is doing social play because they don't like each other enough.
嗯，这取决于物种。但确实如此，有些物种如果你把两只章鱼放在同一个水箱里，最后只会剩下一只安然无恙的章鱼。这是整个类群的一个特征，这意味着你绝对不能指望它们变得真正具有社交性，因为它们在潜在意义上至少都是同类相食的。这就是为什么你不会看到章鱼进行社交性玩耍，因为它们彼此之间还不够喜欢对方。
You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你曾说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那些台阶罢了。我们省了多少？够了。够迷失自我的了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店。欢迎来到您的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on to. now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. You also teach a course in human-animal interaction. How did you get interested in that topic and how does it tie in with your research on cephalopods? Well, I'm in a psychology department and I teach psychology courses. So, of course, I have one foot. in the psychology kingdom. But on the other hand, I have a master's in biology.
希尔顿促销活动现在也正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，最高可省 20%，获得您期待的住宿体验。当您想要省钱而非惊喜时。您住哪里很重要。希尔顿，静享精彩住宿。你还教授一门关于人与动物互动的课程。你是如何对这个课题产生兴趣的，这与你对头足类动物的研究又是如何联系起来的？嗯，我在心理学系，教授心理学课程。所以，当然，我一只脚踏在心理学王国里。但另一方面，我拥有生物学硕士学位。
And clearly a lot of understanding of biology as a general sweep. So in some ways, I found myself at the boundary. And one of the courses I taught for, I think, 25, 30 years was human perception. And I found it particularly useful to be able to teach human perception while having a knowledge of what I would call the sweep in the scope of perception across the animal kingdom because I didn't just see our sensory input as something that was special and different and only for us. I could compare it with other animal sensation.
显然对作为一个整体的生物学有很深的理解。所以在某种程度上，我发现自己处于学科的边缘。我教了大概 25、30 年的其中一门课程是“人类知觉”。我发现，在教授人类知觉的同时，如果能对动物界知觉的广度和范围有所了解，会特别有用，因为我并不认为我们的感觉输入是某种特殊的、不同的、专属于我们的东西。我可以把它与其他动物的感觉进行对比。
So I remember how it started actually because I have been working on animal welfare because the invertebrates in general are not protected in research, even in the United States right now, they're not yet protected. And we had a department member who became ill, and the department chair came to me and said, do you think you can teach anything in animal behavior, some kind of seminar that has something to do with the welfare stuff? And I thought, oh, sure, because if you think about it,
所以我还记得它是怎么开始的，实际上是因为我一直在研究动物福利，因为无脊椎动物总体上在研究中是不受保护的，甚至在美国现在，它们也尚未受到保护。我们系里有一位成员生病了，系主任来找我问：“你觉得你能教点动物行为学方面的内容吗？某种与福利问题有关的研讨会？”我想，哦，当然，因为如果你想想看，
we're in a world full of animals. And we don't really think about the interactions with them. And they're very, very important because we are now, as people keep saying, in the Anthropocene. Everything that we do is affecting every animal. So I designed, of course, that would help get at that. And my students enjoy it very much, actually, because it kind of opens their eyes to things that they haven't thought about that they are doing and seeing. But one of the things I had them do to begin with is talk about their individual philosophy with, regards to animals. And to begin with, I used the Western philosophers. And I thought, wait a minute,
我们生活在一个充满动物的世界里。而我们并没有真正思考过与它们的互动。这非常非常重要，因为正如人们一直所说的那样，我们现在正处于“人类世”。我们所做的每一件事都在影响着每一只动物。所以我设计了一门有助于深入探讨这一点的课程。事实上，我的学生们非常喜欢它，因为它确实让他们大开眼界，看到了他们以前从未想过自己正在做和正在看的事情。但其中一件事，我一开始让他们做的是讨论他们各自对动物的哲学观。一开始，我用的是西方哲学家们的观点。然后我想，等一下，
wait a minute, we're not the only philosophy game in town. So I got a Plains Indian philosophy. And I got Buddhist philosophy. And then I said, the students, okay, here's some examples. Each of you should think about what yours is. But then I went over the different situations in which we do interact with animals and I said, okay, we're going to start at the closest possible. And every year I see my students saying, oh, dogs and cats. And I said, parasites. Think of leeches. Think of nets. And lately I detour to telling them about the human microbiome, which is very important in our psychological and physiological functioning. And yet we're only learning about it. It's amazing to think about it. A huge proportion of us is not us.
等一下，我们可不是城里唯一玩哲学游戏的。所以我引入了大平原印第安人的哲学。我还引入了佛教哲学。然后我对学生们说：“好吧，这里有一些例子。你们每个人都应该想想你们自己的哲学是什么。”接着我回顾了我们与动物互动的不同情境，并说道：“好吧，我们要从距离最近的互动开始。”每年我都看到我的学生们说：“哦，猫和狗。”然后我说：“寄生虫。想想水蛭。想想蚊子。”最近我绕道跟他们讲了人类微生物组，这对我们的心理和生理功能非常重要。然而我们才刚刚开始了解它。一想到这，真令人惊叹。我们体内很大一部分其实并不是我们。
Or as I said to my students, you know, you see me walking across the classroom floor, but actually, I'm a community. I want to go back to something you said a minute ago about how octopuses are not protected in research. What do you mean by that? How are they not protected? How should they be protected? It is about to change. But presently, the U.S. Department of Agriculture rules say that you're could do anything to an inverteerate that you could do to dissected out piece of tissue, which is pretty horrible if you think of an octopus. Way back in the 1990s, I had a colleague who was on the Canadian Council of Animal Care, and she came down the hallway to meet one day and said,
或者正如我对我的学生们所说的那样，你知道的，你看到我走过教室地板，但实际上，我是一个社群。我想回到你刚才说的一分钟前的话题，关于章鱼在研究中是如何不受保护的。你是什么意思？它们怎么不受保护了？它们应该如何受到保护？这种情况即将改变。但目前，美国农业部的规则规定，你对无脊椎动物可以做任何你可以对切下来的一块组织做的事情，如果你想到的是一只章鱼，这其实挺可怕的。早在 20 世纪 90 年代，我有一位同事是加拿大动物护理委员会（Canadian Council of Animal Care）的成员，有一天她顺着走廊来见我，说道：
do you think of your octopus as a tissue? And I said, no, of course not. But because she was a member of the CCAC, she set up a mini-committee. And in Canada, we were the first to say, some invertebrates, specifically cephalopods, are protected in research as same as vertebrates. When the European Union organized, they thought about this and discussed this and consulted with people like me who knew about these things and decided that this should be true in the EU. When the UK broke off from the EU in Brexit, they had for quite a while, a group called Custation.
“你把你的章鱼当成组织来看待吗？”我说：“不，当然不是。”但因为她是 CCAC 的成员，她成立了一个小型委员会。在加拿大，我们是第一批提出以下观点的人：某些无脊椎动物，特别是头足类动物，在研究中应受到与脊椎动物相同的保护。当欧盟组织起来时，他们考虑并讨论了这一点，并咨询了像我这样了解这些事情的人，并决定这在欧盟应该成为现实。当英国通过“脱欧”从欧盟分离开来时，他们有一段时间成立了一个名为“甲壳类动物同情组织”（Crustacean Compassion）的团体。
compassion. And these people say, hey, we need to protect cephalopods, but we need to protect decopod crustaceans, shrimp, lobsters, crabs. And they did actually, they got a consultant Jonathan Birch from the London School of Economics. And he wrote a, you know, a major rapport, sent it to the House of Commerce and the House of Congress said, okay, so they're protected. In the United States, there is a group called Physicians for Social Responsibility in Harvard, and they had been agitating for quite a while, specifically to the NIH National Institute of Health, to institute some protection for cephalopods. Now, I guess it was about a year and a half ago.
这些人说：“嘿，我们需要保护头足类动物，但我们也需要保护十足目甲壳类动物——虾、龙虾、螃蟹。”他们确实做到了，他们请了伦敦政治经济学院的顾问乔纳森·伯奇（Jonathan Birch）。他写了一份重大报告，提交给下议院，下议院说：“好吧，那就保护它们吧。”在美国，有一个名为“医师社会责任协会”（Physicians for Social Responsibility）的组织，总部设在哈佛，他们一直在积极奔走了一段时间，特别是向美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）呼吁，要求对头足类动物制定一些保护措施。现在，我猜大概是一年半前吧。
They weren't getting anywhere with NIH, so they decided that they would hold a congressional brief. And they had met some members of Congress and members of the Senate send somebody to listen to the information. And I had the pleasure of making part in a congressional briefing, which is something I could never imagine that I would have done in my life by Zoom. But still, initially the NIH said, oh, well, we don't really know. We don't need to do this. But about three or four months ago, they decided that it probably would be used to. to have some guidelines. And they sent out to everyone their provisional guidelines.
他们在 NIH 那里毫无进展，于是他们决定举办一次国会简报会。他们会见了国会议员和参议员，并派人来听取相关信息。我有幸通过 Zoom 参加了国会简报会，这可以说是我这辈子做梦也没想到自己会做的事情。不过，最初 NIH 表示：“哦，好吧，我们其实并不清楚。我们不需要这么做。”但大约三四个月前，他们决定制定一些指南可能会很有用。他们向所有人发送了他们的临时指南。
And the physicians for social responsibility be looked at it and said, no, no, it's not good enough because you just say it's suggested. It should be actually a rule. And we're waiting to see what happens. I think in the end it will be required that cephalopods would be protected. I should say, by the way, that I've done research with colleagues in universities Southern California in New York, and most of the people who care about animal welfare in universities treat the cephalopause as honorary vertebrates.
而“医师社会责任协会”看后表示：“不，不，这还不够好，因为你只是说这是一种‘建议’。这实际上应该是一条规则。”我们正拭目以待接下来会发生什么。我认为最终将会有强制规定保护头足类动物。顺便说一下，我应该指出，我曾与南加州大学和纽约大学的同事一起进行过研究，大学里大多数关心动物福利的人都将头足类动物视为荣誉脊椎动物。
But we have a long way to go. There's still most of the countries in the world that don't protect these animals at all. So just I'm wondering as a psychologist how you, you got so interested in cephalopods and octopuses in particular? But it was actually the other way around. I grew up beside the ocean and I got fascinated with intertidal animals. And I thought, okay, I'm going to study sea animals. And so I did my bachelors and masters in biology departments.
但我们还有很长的路要走。世界上仍然有绝大多数国家根本不保护这些动物。所以，我只是想知道，作为一个心理学家，你是怎么对头足类动物、尤其是章鱼产生这么大兴趣的？但其实情况正好相反。我在海边长大，对潮间带动物着迷。我想：“好吧，我要研究海洋动物。”于是我在生物学系读完了学士和硕士学位。
And my professor, when I was a Bill Herr kind of Florida State University, He said, you know, you should really go do your PhD with somebody who was working with Octopus behavior. And there weren't very many people doing Octopus behavior. There still aren't. Okay, there should be more. But I went to work with a professor who was in a psychology department. And he was what we sometimes call on the business, a toxic professor. And when he realized I was good, he didn't want to work with me anymore.
当我在佛罗里达州立大学的威廉·赫尔（Bill Herrn）手下时，我的教授说：“你知道，你真的应该去跟一位从事章鱼行为研究的人攻读博士学位。”当时从事章鱼行为研究的人并不多。现在依然不多。好吧，应该有更多人研究才对。但我去跟一位在心理学系的教授工作了。他有时被业内的同行称为“有毒的教授”。当他意识到我很优秀时，他就不想再和我合作了。
So I finished my PhD with another professor working with human. sensory motor coordination. And gradually, I drifted back to purely cephalopods, but I've got, as I said, one foot in each camp. Now, I mentioned in my introduction that you were an advisor to the Netflix documentary, my octopus teacher. How did that come about? And just as a follow-up for those of us who have seen it, did it do a good job of reflecting and capturing the range of octopus behavior that you've seen in your research? Well, Craig Foster, who's the producer of my octopus teacher have previously sent some footage to the BBC Blue Planet series. And the BBC Blue Planet series are very, very picky about making sure the biology is correct. I love them for
所以我换了另一位教授，研究人类感觉运动协调，并以此完成了我的博士学位。渐渐地，我又回到了纯粹研究头足类动物的道路上，但正如我所说，我两边阵营各踩一只脚。现在，我在引言中提到你是 Netflix 纪录片《我的章鱼老师》的顾问。这事是怎么促成的？作为一个后续问题，对于我们这些看过这部纪录片的人来说，它在反映和捕捉你在研究中所见过的章鱼行为的多样性方面，做得好吗？嗯，《我的章鱼老师》的制作人克雷格·福斯特（Craig Foster）以前曾向 BBC 的《蓝色星球》（Blue Planet）系列节目发送过一些素材。BBC 的《蓝色星球》系列对确保生物学准确性非常非常挑剔。我很喜欢他们这一点。
that. So they got in touch with me and said, hey, we want to know if this footage that we've got is accurate. Would you take a look at it? I said, sure, I worked with them for a while. And at the end of that time, the producers said, by the way, the filmmaker would kind of like to talk to you. He said, okay, if we give me your email, sure, her, no problem. And so that's how I found out that he was doing the film. And he said, you know, he wanted to be as picky about making sure the behavior was correct as the BBC people were. And that, once again, was fine with me. So they flew me to South Africa for 10 days so we could look over film footage and see that it was accurate.
所以他们联系了我，说：“嘿，我们想知道手头的这些素材是否准确。你能看一下吗？”我说：“当然。”我和他们合作了一段时间。在那段时间结束时，制作人说：“顺便说一句，这位电影制作人挺想跟你聊聊的。”他说：“如果我把你的电子邮件给他，行吗？”我说：“当然，没问题。”这就是我得知他正在拍这部电影的原因。他说，你知道的，他想像 BBC 的人那样对确保行为准确性一丝不苟。而这一点，对我来说再次完全没问题。于是他们用飞机把我接到南非待了 10 天，这样我们就可以审查电影素材，确保其准确无误.
And he's, in some ways, the way I am, he's actually a naturalist. I mean, he's a very good filmmaker, but he's very, very interested in the natural world belongs to an organization that's working on saving the oceans, and he's particularly interested in the kelp forests. So he was fun to work with, and in fact, I had my sabbatical last year for six months, and I went back to South Africa, visited with him, and also ended up directing a student in University of Cape Town. So it was a very nice association.
在某些方面，他和我一样，其实是个自然主义者。我的意思是，他是一个非常优秀的电影制作人，但他对自然界非常非常感兴趣，他属于一个致力于拯救海洋的组织，并且对海带森林特别感兴趣。所以和他合作很愉快，事实上，我去年有六个月的学术休假，我回到了南非去看望了他，最后还指导了开普敦大学的一名学生。所以这是一段非常美好的交往。
He is doing something that I think is quite surprising. And I'm very jealous, by the way. He lives just up the hill from his smuggling site. He goes swimming every day. And he's decided he wants to find 1,000 animal species in this kelm forest. Oh, I should say, by the way, that by his sort of dog watching what's going on, he has already discovered a few species. that are new to science.
他正在做一件我认为相当令人惊叹的事情。顺便说一句，我真的很嫉妒他。他就住在离他潜水地点只有一山之坡的地方。他每天都去游泳。他决定在这片海带森林里找到 1,000 种动物。哦，顺便说一句，我应该说，通过他这样日复一日地观察所发生的事情，他已经发现了几种对科学界来说全新物种。
Wow, that's great. And he works with a scientist at the University of Kingtown. Actually, his particular individual has 100 new species to his name. But I think Craig has discovered about four or five of them. So it's a wonderful association. Not too shabby. That's amazing. We should do an awful lot more of that, actually.
哇，这太棒了。他与开普敦大学的一位科学家合作。实际上，他个人名下有 100 种新物种。但我认为克雷格已经发现了其中的四五种。所以这是一个美妙的合作。相当不错。这太神奇了。实际上，我们应该在这方面做更多的事情。
Citizen science is something that I firmly believe in. It belongs to them. It belongs to the people. Science is funded by the people, supported by those people. They have every right to know. And besides, it's fascinating. They should know. So I'm always happy to talk to anybody of all cephalots.
公民科学是我坚信不疑的事情。科学属于大众。科学属于人民，由人民资助，由这些人支持。他们完全有权知道。除此之外，这非常迷人。他们理应了解。所以我总是很高兴能和任何人谈论所有关于头足类动物的话题。
How is the study of octopuses translating into the study and the understanding of other animals? The simplest first step is to say that we always presumed that mammals, particularly primates, particularly homo sapiens, kind of had the corner on intelligence. And so the only model we have for evolution of intelligence was the higher mammals. But then you turn around and you say, wait a minute, there's another model. And when you say there's another model, you stop thinking that you know the way it happens. When you say there's two ways that you can talk about the evolution of intelligence, then you say, oh, okay.
对章鱼的研究是如何转化为对其他动物的研究和理解的？最简单的第一步是指出，我们总是假定哺乳动物，特别是灵长类动物，尤其是智人，在智能方面占尽优势。因此，我们关于智能进化的唯一模型就是高等哺乳动物。但随后你转念一想，说：“等一下，还有另一个模型。”当你提出还有另一个模型时，你就会停止认为自己掌握了事情发生的唯一途径。当你宣称有两种途径可以谈论智能的进化时，你就会说：“哦，好吧。”
Maybe artificial intelligence could use some different way. Maybe other animal species are evolving towards intelligence in a whole different group. Maybe there are different models. And one of the interesting models is the insects. Once again, totally different from us, but totally different from esophopods. And the social insects like the honeybees are very, very interesting. And Lars Chitka has a small. book about the honeybee intelligence.
也许人工智能可以借鉴一些不同的方式。也许其他动物物种正在向完全不同类群的智能进化。也许存在不同的模型。其中一个有趣的模型就是昆虫。再次强调，它们完全不同于我们，但也完全不同于头足类动物。像蜜蜂这样的社会性昆虫非常非常有趣。拉尔斯·奇特卡（Lars Chittka）写了一本关于蜜蜂智力的小书。
Anybody who wants to look for a third route should be looking at insects. And there's another reason. Insects are 60% of the animals on the planet. And we have been ignoring them and killing them and demeaning them. And we need to study it. I was just last week reading a study about ants and how carpenter ants have figured out how to amput. legs of their colleagues in the colony, but only if the leg is injured in a certain place. If it's injured too far away from the body, there's no point in amputating, but if it's
任何想寻找第三条途径的人都应该看看昆虫。还有一个原因。昆虫占了地球上动物的 60%。而我们一直在忽视它们、杀死它们、贬低它们。我们需要研究它们。就在上周，我读到一项关于蚂蚁的研究，研究发现木工蚁已经弄清楚了如何截肢群体中同伴的腿，但前提是腿在特定部位受伤。如果受伤部位离身体太远，截肢就没有意义，但如果是
close to the body, they can amputate it, and the ant will continue to live. It will survive. Interesting. So I'll give you an example of cross-group abilities. I used to think there are three species groups that garden. one of them of course is homo sapiens one of them is the leaf cutter ants that take pieces of leaf down into a refugium I guess and the fungus degrades the leaf and the ants use fungus as food but there's a third one there's a limpid if you think of the top hat shell that clings onto the rocks
靠近身体，它们就可以截肢，蚂蚁还会继续活下去。它能存活下来。有趣。所以我要给你们举一个跨类群能力的例子。我以前认为有三个物种群会进行园艺。其中一个当然是智人，其中一个切叶蚁把树叶碎片带到某个避难所里，我想真菌会降解树叶，蚂蚁把真菌作为食物。但还有第三个，有一种笠螺，如果你想到那种紧贴在岩石上的礼帽形贝壳。
There is a large lipet named Lottia, which is often called the owl lipid. And it turns out that the females guard a territory, scrape algae off the rocks. But they'll go to one place, and then the next day they'll go to another place, and in terms of that there are mucus trails that they make out of the way, fertilize the algae. And they actually knock invaders off the rocks. If they come along like a little sort of front-end loader, bam! and I love it. You're trying to picture a limpid doing that.
有一种名为 Lottia 的大型笠螺，通常被称为猫头鹰笠螺。事实证明，雌性会保卫领地，从岩石上刮下藻类。但它们会去一个地方，第二天又去另一个地方，通过它们留下的粘液痕迹，为藻类施肥。它们实际上会把入侵者从岩石上撞下去。如果它们像某种小型前端装载机一样靠近——砰！我太喜欢了。你试着想象一只笠螺做出那种举动。
Yes, I've never seen a picture, but someone's got to. That's pretty amazing. But it's only the females. Oh. And they kick the males off if they don't want them for sex. But I was telling an insect specialist about this at the Animal Behavior Conference, and he said there's a kind of beetle that cultivates fungus. So I have to find out more about that.
是的，我从未见过图片，但总得有人拍到。这太神奇了。但只有雌性会这么做。哦。如果它们不想和雄性交配，就会把雄性踢开。但我在动物行为学会议上把这件事讲给一个昆虫专家听时，他说有一种甲虫也会培养真菌。所以我得去多了解一下那件事。
That's four. It's still interesting to think about because gardens, of course, made a huge difference to our species. And we tend to think of that, I think, is one of the manifestations of intelligence, but we're not alone in doing it. Well, clearly you have a very inquisitive mind, so I'm wondering what's next for you? What else are you working on these days? Well, I have a book. It's nearly finished, and it's actually the marine ecosystems and how the marine ecosystems work. So there's three chapters looking at the things that are critical in the marine ecosystems. So one of them is movement. One of them is perception. And again, this is,
那是第四个。思考这些依然很有趣，因为园艺当然给我们的物种带来了巨大的改变。我们往往认为这可以说是智能的表现之一，但我们并不是唯一会这么做的生物。嗯，显然你有着一颗极具探究精神的心，所以我很好奇，你的下一步是什么？这几天你还在研究什么？嗯，我有一本书。快写完了，其实是关于海洋生态系统以及海洋生态系统是如何运作的。所以有三个章节探讨了对海洋生态系统至关重要的事物。其中一个是运动。一个是知觉。同样，这也是，
of course, where my background in perception comes in handy. And one of them is buoyancy. So I'll give you an example from the buoyancy chapter, the magic number 1.025. What do you think that might be? I don't know. The density of water. I don't know. Very good. Did I get it? the density of distilled water is 1.000-0-0.025 is the density of salt water. Good for you. I was a bio-major. So why is that critical? Because you float in salt water. Right. So if you float in salt water, you're fine. But if you don't, you sink.
当然，这正是我的感知背景派上用场的地方。其中一个例子就是浮力。我给你举一个浮力章节中的例子，神奇数字1.025。你觉得那可能是什么？我不知道。水的密度。我不知道。很好。我猜对了？蒸馏水的密度是1.000，0.025是盐水的密度。真棒。我是生物专业出身的。那么为什么这至关重要？因为你在盐水中会浮起来。没错。所以如果你在盐水中浮起来，你就没事。但如果你不浮，你就会下沉。
And the sunshine is up there. The plankton are up there. So somehow, or other pretty well every marine animal has to deal with, what do you do about your buoyancy? Some of them have fluids with air. Some of them have ammonia in their tissues. Some of them just keep moving. Tuna just keep moving. But life in the open ocean is about figuring out how not to sink. Well, I look forward to seeing your book.
阳光在那里。浮游生物在那里。所以不管怎样，几乎所有海洋动物都必须应对一个问题：你该如何处理你的浮力？它们中的一些体内有含空气的液体。一些组织的含有氨。一些只是不停地游动。金枪鱼就是不停地游动。但是开放大洋中的生活，就是要弄清楚如何才能不沉下去。嗯，我很期待看到你的书。
so keep us posted here on Speaking of Psychology. We'll talk again. I want to thank you very much for joining me, Dr. Mather. This has been really interesting. It's been fun. Thanks for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.spinkingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman.
所以请在我们的《心理学播客》（Speaking of Psychology）上随时向我们通报最新进展。我们还会再聊。非常感谢您能来，马瑟博士。这真的很有趣。这很有意思。谢谢邀请我。您可以在我们的网站 www.spinkingof Psychology.org，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 以及您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学播客》的往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学播客》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。
Thank you for listening, the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听，我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。